les sirènes ont retenti à travers toute
l'ukraine au petit matin ce samedi y
compris ici à lviv c'était à 5h30
connaît entendu on a été réveillés par
l' alerte mais il n'y a pas eu
confirmation d'une quelconque attaque
dans cette région la région de lviv mais
pour ce qui est des endroits qui n'avait
pas vraiment été ciblés depuis le début
de cette guerre à dnipro dans le centre
est du pays pour une deuxième journée de
suite il y a eu des tirs sur cette ville
les militaires ukrainiens affirment
avoir abattu deux roquettes qui visaient
cette ville denis pro marioupol bien sûr
dans le sud est restent de cible de
bombardements intensive et la ville est
complètement bloqué c'est vraiment une
catastrophe humanitaire à marioupol où
les gens n'ont pas à manger à boire très
très peu de contact avec le monde
extérieur et ne peuvent pas sortir de la
ville voilà plus d'une semaine que healy
a dit tentative d'évacuer les habitants
de marioupol et ils sont un demi million
et sans succès puisque les les
bombardements ne cesse pas une autre
ville qui est encerclée c'est cher
ninive au nord de kiev dans le nord de
l'ukraine très très difficile de sortir
de tchernigov et ce matin cette ville
elle aussi a été ciblé par une roquette
russe qui selon mes informations a
touché un hôtel dans le centre-ville du
l'hiver là où vous êtes quel est le
sentiment de la population quels sont
leurs espérances quelles sont leurs
attentes
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de craintes
en ukraine même si il est clair que les
ukrainiens et je pense le monde entier
ne s'attendait pas à une défense aussi
bien organisée et aussi déterminée de la
part de l'ukraine donc d'une part il ya
une très grande fierté il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d images sur internet de par
exemple agriculteurs ukrainiens qui sont
en train de ramener des tanks russes des
tirs et d'être en crise derrière leurs
tracteurs heures des blagues en ce sens
vive par exemple il y a des pancartes
partout de blagues sur les russes d'un
humour assez assez noir peut-être mais
vraiment qui montre un esprit très
combatif chez les ukrainiens et aussi
beaucoup de haine contre les russes mais
il ya aussi bien sûr beaucoup de
craintes sur quels seront les intentions
ultérieure de vladimir poutine quelle
arme est il prêt à utiliser l'armé
nucléaire on en parle les armes
chimiques maintenant les etats-unis ont
mis en garde contre la possibilité que
les russes pouvaient essayer d'organiser
une sorte de provocation pour ensuite
avoir une excuse pour utiliser les armes
chimiques
les rumeurs circulent partout donc le
payer et très nerveux quant aux
tactiques prochaine de kev et aux cibles
dont l'avenir proche bien sûr tout le
monde a les yeux rivés sur deux endroits
surtout c'est kiev et un mic alive est
ce que les russes vont arriver à
encercler qui est pour le moment ils
n'ont pas pris la ville de bath équipe
ce qui fait que le quart sud-est si vous
voulez pour sortir et rentrer dans
lequel reste ouverte il est encore
possible d'accéder à la capitale
ukrainienne est-ce que cela va durer ou
est ce qu'ils ont l'intention
d'encercler la ville est compensée un
bombardement beaucoup plus intensifs et
au cimic alive une ville stratégique
dans le sud de l'ukraine que les russes
n'ont pas réussi à prendre pour le
moment est-ce qu'ils vont essayer
peut-être de contourner plus tôt cette
ville et ensuite la cible suivante selon
la logique serait le port du sud de
l'ukraine au dessin